oh my kindness I've got no direct
connection with the experimentalists and
the theorist and but there is a fun
connection
um I think and I did my my bachelor's
degree my undergraduate degree in the
1980s early 1980s
and in 1982 I took my first quantum
mechanics course
and the quantum mechanics course was
taught by wonderful guy called John
Martin and but we calculated you know we
things like energy levels of the
hydrogen atom we would calculate spins
and in magnetic fields Stone gear like
experiments and it all worked
beautifully but we just calculate
and and using using sort of high
Schrodinger equation and solving this
and then at the end he said well okay
we've seen how brilliantly it works
here's a
here's something that um Einstein who of
course got a Nobel Prize not for
relativity he got it for his work on the
photoelectric effect which is quantum
mechanics
Einstein was not very happy with the
elements of content Theory and he so he
told us John told us you should go and
read this four page paper written in
1935 by Einstein Rosen podolsky in which
they sort of set up a a test case of
thought experiment which sort of shows
the limitations of understanding
content mechanics you you create two
particles to mix them together
um so that they kind of a bound or what
and how is a Schrodinger called entangle
and then you move them apart
and then you do an experiment on this
one
and this these could be millions of
miles apart in principle you do an
experiment on this one to determine some
property of it and it immediately tells
you what the what this one is you
haven't even looked at this one but you
know exactly the property of this and
you can do the same you can look at a
different property on this and it will
tell you what the property of this is
and Einstein just kind of naturally said
this can't be right this looks like it's
you called it spooky action at the
distance so my teacher was telling us
this and and I'll began thinking oh my
God yeah what what's what's going on
here you know what how's the signal gone
from there to there to explain it and um
and he said the teacher went on to say
well this guy David Bohm he also was
worried about this following having read
Einstein's work this Paradox and he said
he came up with an idea called which
became known as hidden variables and he
wrote some papers in which he sort of
the idea there is quantum mechanics
isn't the be all and end-all there's
something else sort of underneath it if
you like some variables which are
playing roles in which case in this case
the two particles would not actually
know what their properties really are
and so it wouldn't be a surprise that
when you went out here did a measurement
this one was the value it was because
they were already embedded in the hidden
variables and he said um
and that then LED John Bell to come up
with his test because John Bell was also
a skeptic in the sense of he didn't
really like the idea that quantum
mechanics was providing us with this
this kind of instantaneous result he
came up with a test which he heard about
David Baum's work he read it being the
brilliant guy he was he realized he
could come up with some some look for
some correlations between events and see
what this should be in the hidden
variables Theory and compare them to
what they should be in the quantum
mechanics case
and he realized and this is what Mike
talks about there is a bound that
emerges in the hidden variables theory
that all these correlations have to be
less than this given bound but it's
possible in the quantum mechanics case
because you can have these extreme
correlations that it can be bigger than
this bound
and then that's the experimentalist the
three experimentalists actually got
interested in in this paper of bells and
they that they've got their Nobel Prize
because they actually went and developed
experiments which tested this Bell's
inequality and found that it was always
being violated
but my little connection is the at the
end of the lecture he said to us and for
those of you who are interested David
Baum is actually a professor at birkbeck
it's 1982 and he's giving a a lecture
today on the aspect experiment because
he's aware of it and he said you might
want to go so me and Mama Wilkinson said
we haven't got a clue what's going on
we barely knew what wave function was
we'd only taken one course in quantum
mechanics but it sounded important so he
said well let's go and we'll have a beer
afterwards so so we we went we trudged a
lot across London it's from King's
College where we were to put it back we
found the room there was only about 20
people in the room
um and um David Bowman was there was
very senior Professor by then and um he
he introduced as to the idea of hidden
variables this is what you know I'm
talking 40 years ago so you have to bear
this environment I might have even I
wasn't even sure what his conclusions
were in the end but I think I know what
they were and he was telling us about
the hidden variable and then he told us
about the aspect experiment
which was stunning I do remember
thinking that because aspect had
introduced these amazing switches which
would as the as the particles or the
photons were moving from from their
Source outwards the switches would be
going millions of times a second and so
that it would determine which detector
the particle went to there was a
Randomness in it and that was really
important
but um he then went on just to say uh
and indeed it looks like local hidden
variable theories and are ruled out by
this because of this the results are
bigger than this uh bound that Bell had
um derived but he said but that doesn't
actually rule out hidden variable
theories he said I need
produced a sort of some modifications of
it which were perfectly from what I
remember were perfectly okay and in fact
then I that then prompted us he then
produced a book called wholeness in the
implica in wholeness and the implicate
order I think it's called and um he said
you might want to read about it in this
book so we went and indeed we went on
the way back past file's Bookshop and
bought the book
I'm talking with you yeah
that's the actual copy yeah
Hubble Space Telescope image of the
Galaxy and it might also give you some
idea of the scale and the fact that it
just doesn't fit on the Hubble CCD and
you can really see those dark dust Bands
then essentially what they do is block
visible light it's essentially hiding
what's behind that in the galaxy from
that region